would you rise sir would you rise
japanese
no chinese chinese sure since the water
all chinese
now you guys weren't religious at all
your dad is but you didn't
you found the area you were whacking off
at like 12. you were like
i can't go back joseph smith didn't have
this [ __ ] right here
you know if he had pornhub he would have
never left new york
he would have been in his basement like
i found jesus
anybody married longer than 36 years
you're the winners go to the parking lot
pick whatever car you want
take it home how do you guys keep it
fresh you ever just switch teeth and
look at each other
i'm sorry that was a dick move but i had
to tell a joke i apologize
how did you meet how did you meet
remember there was a day you didn't know
him and then there was a day you did
what's that how did you mean cruising on
e
street
wow you're not supposed to marry a
hooker
must have been a great cruise
i don't know if you're a hooker mama
congratulations if you are
it's the best gig ever 36 years
your pimp is gonna be pissed when you
get back
are you in a band yeah what's your band
avon abstract
avant abstract oh my god
free file pretty fast
i did my business cards in that font
where's the rest of your banner is it
just youtube i feel like it's just
youtube
there's uh there's one more guy but he's
not here where is he
i don't know not a todd berry fan huh is
he the singer
no he plays guitar who sings no one
oh you're oh an instrumental band
it's worse than i thought
[Applause]
chinese japanese filipino my ass you're
a [ __ ]
i'll tell you this three years in the
jungle looking for your uncle
i'll tell you this god bless you my
friend what is your first name
joe joe my ass joe
during world war ii they were all joe
you're a jew you got to be with that
nose if you're not you're an eagle
i'll tell you this
it's actually it's nice to have you here
this evening because i think one of the
charity gigs i did
help pay for the minibus that brought
you here
this gentleman in the front with a
salmon-colored shirt on
i was wondering if you had any advice
for young comedians that you generally
give and
are you thinking of doing comedy um
i've never done it before but watching
you has made me want to try it
[Applause]
i don't know if there's an insult or not
it's a it's a compliment it's it's i
mean [ __ ] don't say i've never done
brain surgery but it looked
a lot easier than i thought
and you bro you're indian yeah i could
see that um
i i have eyes um
i'm glad you're here he's having a
problem with his laptop and um
[Applause]
but you were born in india it seems like
to me yeah i could tell like
we could just we just know we just know
it's a body language thing like
people born very uncomfortable
you know what it means like immigrants
have a different body language than
people are from you like people from
you're like oh what's up and then
immigrants like hello
it could be white people they do the
same thing it's
and what's your name what happened
oh say that again varma your name is
varma
isn't that your last name that's your
first name and what's your full name
i don't know like he said but it sounds
like it sounded like that
and that's your wife with you yes why'd
you look how many [ __ ] you got on the
go
[Applause]
and what's your name spin heart what
come on the car um
not in the summer you ruined the paint
um
first time what's that
hi thanks for shouting out like a crazy
[ __ ] that's growing up
i'll abuse you so badly your
gynecologist don't think you've been in
a [ __ ] car crash
what's your name buddy johnny how you
doing john happy [ __ ] to be connie
johnny what is your question all right
you know um women talk about you know
what is your [ __ ] voice
[Applause]
his [ __ ] son you know who he
sound like he sounded like d-ray i'm
like where are your blue vests at
is that d-ray all right yeah we're gonna
talk about what are you doing
i really feel like you're about to say
okay anderson we're on the scene right
now
and it is going crazy down here in
baltimore things are wild
give us the scoop good luck to you i
spoke to the people in bethlehem they
expect
you nice to see you what do you do for a
living jeff
nothing nothing
[Laughter]
all right johnny talk to us for real
though you know women talk about how you
know
hey come on come on man
stop man you [ __ ] with us bro you got
to be [ __ ] with us man
nice to see you what do you do for a
living mr callus i'm an optometrist oh
wonderful i hope it goes away
maybe that would be all right for you an
optometrist
better than sitting around on the beach
all day waiting for birds to die
what do you do back in ohio
you get up in the morning go to a
building what does it say on the front
of it
you work for a trash company are you a
trash lady
he's a trash man you work in the office
and
that's how you met
you guys said we're carpooling one way
or another
we're working at the same place one of
us is going outside one of us is staying
inside
and i better not see another person's
spoon in your yogurt
i can't imagine going to the same place
as my wife every day
you ever bring her something back from
the truck
hey baby got a half-eaten blueberry
you love me how did you meet her how did
you become love us
craigslist holy [ __ ]
[Applause]
oh my god well i look forward to seeing
you guys on 48 hours
cause i honestly don't think you're
supposed to have a relationship
from craigslist i think you're supposed
to get a couch and
maybe something in the parking lot but
that's it
i've never even heard that before well
no wonder you guys work in trash
you're craigslist people for christ's
sake you must you must see half a couch
all the time and think i can sell that
sound like all this [ __ ] this
distraction
i like her though when i'm saying i like
you did you say i like her though you
repeating exactly what
who the [ __ ] you talking to first of all
like who's that because i'm a couple i
only want y'all to read my lips that's
how i know what i am
so anyway
hey don't don't do the thing
trying to be mr stenographer gay guy
that's a woman's job [ __ ]
[Music]
and then how do you fit here you're just
[ __ ] blocking this whole social network
do you even know them at all you don't
know them at all they just threw the
ethnically ambiguous people all at one
table
that is how people work they looked at
your face they were like [ __ ] she
fits
probably from bangladesh or some [ __ ]
they'll figure it out
put her at the punjabi mc table would
you put it at the punjabi mc table thank
you very much
are you doing me man are you a weird
looking straight guy or a really weird
looking gay guy
i'd come on your face just to cover it
up
that was your [ __ ] effort was it when
your mum gave birth she
shot you so she could leave her [ __ ]
free for [ __ ] the doctors
i love swearing i've always quite sorry
what was that i missed a bit of chat
hi sorry it's not the telly if you talk
i can hear
a big son of a gun all right guys you
ever think of putting a window on your
face and becoming a building
you beautiful people you're a
good-looking dude hey that's what's up
yeah
no you got it you got it he's a
good-looking dude no you look like
common with cancer
you're a black man right i took a guess
i'll take it
rough enough being a black man but
you're dressed up for a trick-or-treat
party i'll tell you that
there's a lot of cliches about gypsies
maybe you can help me out this sir
have you ever tarmac to drive no of
course not you just take the deposit and
[ __ ] off like the rest of it
come here what's your first name yes
you're a good sport russ cause you can
laugh at this
what's your first name my darling jewel
and how long you've been married
two years he's 300 pounds don't you get
worried when he makes his move
just do what you're doing now
what are you guys you're just friends
you never hook up at all
you've never done anything never
now what we're in the show we stay show
me that dyke [ __ ]
you got vicarious glasses
[Applause]
no you're hot you're a hot lesbian give
me the glasses y'all let me show you
listen these guys right here you ate
some [ __ ] man i'm sorry look at this
right i put these shits on i can see
labia on everybody